ain't no competition in the ring
decipher because i'm spitting finally
i'm swinging fire talking pickled
peppers make em pay the piper cause i
might go look like a rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a fool
production you'll be talking like you
want a new concussion center due to
custom attitude adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sandwich i will serve heaven's
tipping moving
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie captain you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him sinking tony
tony tony braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got hands so
i'm ready for the tension i'ma leave him
red you could redemption
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
[Music]
as tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on guys
let me get that emote out of there
okay
so hopefully everything is going uh
as planned
i broke my phone today which is really
nuts
absolutely nuts
all right there we go there we go
let me know if you guys can hear me in
the chat
what's going on fight night is on
yeah
watching the fight right now
so
don't get out with drinks on
um
i'm gonna have a wife come downstairs
bring me i'm echoing
all right let me see why am i echoing
hold on
am i still echoing
let me know if i'm still echoing
suicide kings let me know what's up
let me know let me know
what's absolutely nuts is uh
all right good my echo is gone that's
what's up
good now yeah i had to i had to hit that
media sauce and and drop that off
now now so right now so um
the riverside rocky fighting right now
and he's living up to his name he rough
an old boy up
it's absolutely nuts um i expected this
fight the the you know the undercut to
actually go the way it's going
um you know he fights well off the ropes
uh a little bit of the body shots here
and there it's um it's it's it's
they put in some good work right now i
mean the undercards have been uh pretty
decent uh
i know everybody's asking me who do i
think i'm going was going to win out of
you know spence
and uh ugas um
what i saw on the weigh-in a lot of
people didn't see this
oh boy
spence had a little limp
now i don't know if it's it's
it's an injury
on the leg that has excuse me the full
tattoo
that leg
he has a little limp on it and i don't i
don't know um
if he has an injury going into this
fight or what uh ugas uh looked uh
pretty
pretty solid uh the thing that i didn't
like with uga's throughout his whole
training um he had his uh fiance his
girlfriend or whatever cooking his food
and
i mean at this stage of the game you
should have a nutritionist to be honest
with you you know earl spence is
starting to take his his his stuff to
the next limb
level and um
oh man
oh oh crawley is definitely working uh
lopez lopez uh pushed him up against the
ropes getting kind of messy
so
i don't know if who guys is going to gas
out later on in the fight
i know earl is definitely going to be
there for 100 of the fight right now so
um
what what i'm what i'm thinking about
honestly i'm thinking it's going to go
12 rounds but that all depends on
how
ugas approaches the fight if ulgaz
approaches the fight like he thinks earl
is is um
is is weak or earl
uh can't stand the pressure
then the fight is gonna be an early
night because then he's gonna work into
earl's hands
uh i think his best advantage is to use
his longer reach stay on the outside and
um and pot shot him from a distance if
he can if he can you know earl has
really good defense so
right now what we got is we have um
uh
lopez versus crowley
and
lopez um is on the ropes crowley's uh
putting in a lot of work
hitting a lot of body shots you know
moving in moving out uh throwing a lot
of jabs and you know
it's it's a pretty good fight it's in
the fifth round i think we have one more
before the main
so um
shout out to everybody that's actually
uh
watching the fight uh wanting to know
exactly who's gonna put in the work
who's that uh flames good evening good
evening everyone everyone
so happy that anybody showed up be
honest with you i mean if if you don't
have a friend to hang out with on this
fight night you have a friend like me to
hang out with in them
but i know you're looking like where the
shades at
i gotta read the super chats right
solving here to read my super chat so
can't hear the shades on now got to put
on the glasses
that i put on uh you know the people
keepers
let me see what's up
arrow's eye injury
concerns me
um
bigger earl coming in
that whole car accident concerns me
you know um not just the eye injury you
know he had he had some serious injuries
going into this and that's that's what
takes away from this the fact that
you know
earl himself
is
seemingly okay
the questions is
what does he have and that's that's the
sad part about it right they go see they
just saw errol coming in and they said
ooh guys coming in right now i think
ugass is too worried about being a
superstar be honest with you
i think uh
you know he got the money he beat
pacquiao he got a little bit of fame
and you know he got the pretty girl on
his arm
so i think oogaz is is is worrying about
being uh famous
you know um
this is no time to take your foot off
the damn pedal to be honest with you
this is not it right now
what's going on
all right so
these guys is hugging in the middle of
the ring a little jab a little little
little right hands
i'ma have a wife bring down some stuff
and make some mixed drinks right here
you know it's hey it's saturday
uh it's fight night uh just finished
eating some great white fish
and uh some rice and
white rice beans
uh asparagus and some white fish the
filet
so
pretty good pretty good stuff
and uh definitely gonna get some mixed
drinks on so
i don't know what y'all drinking on but
i'm about to drink on so let me see
danny garcia doesn't throw punches let
me see yourself what's up
it's not danny garcia doesn't throw
punches danny garcia
he he
how can i say he's a counterpuncher he's
a boxer counterpuncher right
so
when when danny garcia is fighting danny
garcia is not going to press the issue
unless he has somebody that is uh of
lesser ilk right so danny he hits hard
though remember he's the one to pop
keisha uh uh keith thurman's shoulder
out
um and he hit uh earl in the ninth round
with a good left hook
that back girl up and earl stop putting
pressure on him so
danny garcia is a top level fighter i
wish danny garcia right now would have
fought um
a bud crawford uh you know because that
fight is available but he didn't want to
take that fight and i don't think bud
wants to take a fight uh before securing
the earl spence fight to be honest with
you i think i think bud is just holding
on outside trying to get the big payday
you know he comes with the one little
wbo belt and to be honest with you he
could have came up when he came up he
was unified uh uh undisputed champion at
his weight class and when he came up to
147 when he came up from 140 to 147 he
could have directly made himself the
mandatory for um earl spence he didn't
do that uh so that showed me right there
he wasn't ready for that he went secure
the wbo belt and then brought himself
over here demanding earl spins fight you
could bypass all that homie i don't fall
for the you know shenanigans be honest
with you
so
it's it's going to be a good fight
either way i still favor earl and that
but i got to see what he does with
olga's tonight i think earl is going to
put the pedal to the middle on this
fight tonight and put in that work but
you know we have lopez versus crowley
right now in the undercard and um
he he's it's looking good we're in the
sixth round closing out last couple of
seconds of the sixth round he's pushing
uh crawley up against the ropes uh lopez
is um body work a little bit you know up
top
and we're going to the seventh round
i broke my phone today
dear god
broke my phone today so hard to make any
type of freaking calls or do anything
um
called in for service to get a new phone
i'm gonna probably more than likely uh
run out to um t-mobile in the morning
and go pick up a new phone so
got pax this week can't be messing
around let me see
oh god girl who wants to be
famous for sure
yo
i have a thing with that like um
when when you're famous
keep keep your girl your wife everybody
separated keep keep them away out of
that you know
um nobody should you know like uh climb
off of uh your hard work getting there
of course if they supportive all the way
through that's fantastic that's
beautiful uh help them you know do a
cooking channel help them do something
whatever they they're good at let them
stay in that space because when you're
in your space you earn that space and
let that space be yours i think her ooh
guys are doing something a little bit
wrong right now floyd learned the hard
lesson of that remember miss jackson
exactly
she's not there no more she's with nelly
right doesn't look the same either their
floyd money have you looking different
let me see what's going on
ah
some lemonade yeah yeah
yeah let me see what's going on
what's going on in this chat
any thoughts of uh connor bennett i love
connor ben
i think connor ben needs to have a step
up fight uh moving forward to be honest
with you kind of ben um is in a space
right now where it's either or to be
honest with you like it's either he's
going to be a bust or he's he's he's
going to uh rise all the way up connor
ben has the power um he has the
determination can he actually um
achieve greatness
is out there if eddie hearn decides to
put him to work
you know um
but uh again remember the pvc actually
holds everybody that's in his division
to fight
so
it's it's really not up to um
conor ben is really up to his promoter
actually getting him into these fights
to mix it up
all right so joselito lopez just got
dropped
all right he got standing eight right
now his head looked and lumped up he had
a hematoma over his eye right now all
right so crawley's uh stepping in moving
in uh sweeping left hook
uh another sweeping left hook straight
into a straight right hand
uh he's he's he's just uh
he's just working them little by little
and it's that sweeping left hook on the
outside when uh lopez reaches in because
lopez wants to work the body but uh
crawley is just definitely just you know
just sweeping left hook that's the left
foot because he can't see it the
hematoma is heavy on his side of his
face so he he definitely can't see it he
can't see it at all
and
it's a detriment to them it's going to
need to be thinking about that and the
hematoma does not look good at all
um especially if you're a body punch and
you're just reaching in all right what
we got here we got uh
who guys pulls off the upset what does
that do to the tournament if you guys
pulls off the upset um you're gonna see
uh earl spins have a rematch you know
regardless to what so that that further
puts uh crawford on the back burner
whereas crawford should have been
fighting thurman should have been
fighting uh uh danny garcia um i thought
that porter fight yo
i got a weird take on it they're friends
man and porter knew that he was going uh
uh
taking a sidestep that's not the same
porter that uh fought um
that fought uh spence to be honest with
you that's not the same portal
you know um but i i i'll see i'll see
hey babe
i can't even text her to tell her to
bring me down the stuff
you said king got glasses as he could
see he was a good fighter that's what's
up
let me see let me see
okay guys we guys let's go let's go
well
the worst thing in the world
is for all guys to
to win the night
i mean not for who guys the worst thing
in the world for uh the division and and
and crawford and
earl spence is full guys to win i mean
for boxing itself it'll put a new
wrinkle out there to force people to do
different things
so
you know josolito lopez is taking this
left hook off the side of his head
and the hematoma is so big
um oh he's he's he's he's messed up man
he's messed up and the guy keeps
targeting it
and and it's just like it's automatic
now it's it's it's kind of disgusting at
the moment it's
and he's doing straight right hands
i mean if i would ask my quantity
i would hope my corner will have my best
interest in heart this this fight needs
to be stopped
but i understand they're trying to take
it to the distance
uh i mean
i think i'm gonna be sipping on some
crushed ice
sunny delight
and shout out to my boy 50 but he's no
longer with effin and some some some
effing right now claire ephron um
that's a start off probably hit some a
little bit of sorak before the main
event
oh shout out to 108 dragons red cups
only
be honest with you
oh
that is a crazy body shot yo so
dudes just dudes was clowning me because
of my little emoji right my little uh
yeah let me let me let me hit that right
we're here
come here
addict taught me how to do it but um
am i doing
i was doing it properly
that ain't working
that's what happens when you when you're
running it yourself
the best body shots in the past decade
um
let me see
uh heavyweight or
or um
or lightweight
if if you want to say lightweight the
best body shots
um
the past decade
damn you went you went deep
past decade man
nobody's really a real body uh
shot
you know uh fighters they they aren't
there anymore like that you know these
dudes is too busy head hunting you would
have to say earl pre-crash that's all he
did was hunt the body like he'll pour
his way in with the jab and hunt the
body
um
then you say the charlo brothers do
pretty good work
you know what i'm gonna have to go with
canelo i think canelo has the best body
attack that is highly underrated um
because everybody's too busy looking at
his right hands or or the left hooks off
the jab i think canelo is a severely
underrated uh body puncher so i would me
personally i would go with canelo i
think canelo is probably the best body
puncher that we got going on right now
ricky hatton
are you crazy
i have a problem with ricky hatton's
opposition
ricky hadn't had a nation pushing behind
him i had a problem with ricky hatton's
opposition because when he actually
stepped up to fight the best and
remember the best two uh either a or b
either one you want to put uh was floyd
and was pacquiao
floyd knocked them out and then pacquiao
knocked them out
right so
um when he did step up to that to that
upper tier competition um ricky hatton
wasn't a factor man you know so
he he had he had a decent run but that
was more hype than anything when he
stepped in there with them real boys the
real boys put him away and they knocked
him out it wasn't like he went the
distance with them you know he got
knocked out both times so and floyd made
his head hit off the turnbuckle and then
he rented oh no no that was absolutely
terrible what we got here
anyway
i want to pick your brains knowledge of
statues boxing that's what's up
co
was a superb all-around boxing you know
kodo gave floyd
the most headache in that run like if
you look at all the fights all the floyd
fights besides the castano naked
castillo fight um
kodo
actually gave floyd the worst uh uh
problems and that's why he respects uh
koto to this day kodo's uh on boxing
ability and his footwork was
severely underrated he was a severe uh
ring technician um
the way he moved around the ring
um
margarito uh
that was an unfortunate fight for him
man they i wish they would check the
gloves and and stuff like that you know
i was a
good margarito fan but um up until all
that stuff to happen i think he should
have been banned from the sport never
ever come back again you know
um
and they put him in there with pacquiao
and pacquiao tore his eye up so he was
never the same after that but
yeah ko koto definitely um one of the
top knox boxes but all around boxing he
had mixed in body shots but he wasn't
just a primary body shot uh fighter let
me see what was going on and what we got
we got canelo is the base
he's a beast so clever vicious and we're
letting your king are you showing the
fight here
can't show the fight here i can talk
about the fight as the fight is going on
you can probably hear a little bit of
the fight but i'm gonna give you round
by round of what's going on for
everything that's going on then you can
get real reactions you're gonna get
prediction right before they fight um
and then you know we're going to talk
about it remember this is
this is a a drink fight you know we just
partying we relax and watching the fight
talking about the fight and uh
any little bit of uh questions you get
you can answer right now
what up attic
um
attic
phones broken
ah so i got to get a phone before we uh
get out of here from packs i'm talking
to the people on the phone i'm like can
you overnight me a phone
um
and they were giving me all types of
headaches man it's
totally ridiculous getting the stuff
that you need done
fast as possible so
i gotta see what can happen but um yeah
i get a replacement phone it's not gonna
cost me too much i mean this is a 1600
phone
so well back when i got it it ain't net
now
but man it hit that corner and just
shattered shattered look at the
corner and just shattered
so disgusting so upset with myself
got 33 people in there
got 28 likes that's what's up
love the fact that yeah so listen i
didn't even think jose's joselito lopez
would have made it this far
um
he actually made it a little bit farther
than i expected
uh hold on one
second hey
yeah i muted myself
[Laughter]
said we can't call jose lopez out no we
can't it's 10 to 10. right now carly's
been beating him that hematoma is is
working his eye
so
man listen
he counted himself out
game of all time
um
ring king
yeah
i was playing that today i was playing
ring team ring king today i put on my um
my turbo graphics was playing that then
i was playing a little bit of nintendo
um i got to bring my super nes
downstairs i got to bring that
downstairs
i can't wait for them to do more retro
excuse me consoles
i know i'm definitely gonna um have my
uh
what's that um
uh whenever they get that sega uh saturn
out
or the um
does the dreamcast i definitely want one
of those
should die what's up
[Laughter]
he said ring things
better you know see
okay so the reason why i like green king
is
that when you hit him in the head we hit
him with those left hooks ha ha ha ha
right here and the afro's going poo poo
poo poo yo
that's dope to me that's dope to me but
yeah of course fight night man round
four
of course that you know that's the first
time roy jones looked like roy jones and
everybody looked good you know um that
was the new consoles right that was uh i
think what was that to 360
and dudes was going nuts off that
let me see
punch out punch house deal
shout out to my cousins yeah
yeah hell yeah yeah yeah ring king man
definitely i i'm sorry i remember the
first time i seen it arcade and then
nintendo got it on that nes and
i it was no way i was ever going back it
was just
it was it was all the way live for me so
jose lito lopez is trying but he has a
concussion he's he's he's fighting with
a concussion right now
fight's over thank god
it should have he was about to go to his
corner it should have been stopped be
honest with you four rounds ago
four rounds ago they need to check them
don't let them sleep you know um keep
him up 24 hour surveillance
you know super just just just watch him
man because
he shouldn't take no beating like that
oh time for some beard butter it's beard
butter time guys
whenever i
have a dry beard i reach for beard
butter
yeah that's a
crowley one i mean and this is the first
time i'm seeing crowley fight so
um he had a good account of himself on
the pay-per-view um
yeah that's he was a good accountant
himself
he he he to be uh joselito lopez and
remember jose lita lopez is um
one of the good journeymen that we have
in the sport of boxing but i think he
only have like two three more fights
like that uh taking that type of beating
um
hold on one second guys uh
gotta switch my camera off for a second
i said
bring me the sunny delight
no
what i got
is
the dr pepper
yeah uh-oh dr pepper i need a
sponsorship no i need a sponsorship dr
pepper
all right so you know
so the first drink is not going to be
sunny delight it's going to be dr peppa
red cups only red cups only
shout out to anybody that understands i
don't know is it a new york thing tell
me if it do you have this around the
world uh
in other other places in the world the
red cup is it's the red cup a thing
see
and then i'm a weirdo i gotta hide a red
straw so and then you notice how they
all mix right you notice how it mixed
right so check it out the the red cup
and then the red straw but the cup is
white inside with the and my
straw got the little white twizzler so
what's up
uh
she said she brought what you needed my
brother
that's why you love them right that's
why you love them right that's why can't
see it
has to be off air can't see it
but um yeah that's why you love them so
it is what it is
shout out to pax next week it's gonna be
crazy
anybody that knows about pax
knows the hard work that the lord's put
in and it's going to be nuts let me see
oh you do red cup in the midwest that's
what's up red cup in itself started in
the south
i i'm not i i don't know i'm just
telling i'm from new york so i didn't
start it down there i'm just asking you
we do timberlands and red cups you know
what i'm saying so it is what it is but
the red cup is a red cup red covers in
the uk this is so
this is
that's for sure
that's no lie
i guess any hood in america
you go out there and you know you can't
mess with those dudes that come back and
bring you just to see through little
white customers about those little get
those little
clear cups out of here nobody nobody
does clear cups clay cups is for chumps
brown cup in the uk what brown cup
so y'all got a cup like this but it's
brown
that's crazy
i like to see that
hit me on twitter i probably won't be on
twitter for the next couple of days
being that my phone is in the bushes
but it is what it is right
all right so we got one fight down we
got uh crawley won uh and he should have
won you know um the river shot rocky had
a uh hematoma on the side of his head
that looked disgusting
not good at all bad look so we got one
fight down
and uh you know you got earl and and uh
just came into the arena and it i think
was like round six or something like
that
and uh again
you see earl
alone focused on boxing and you see you
guys focused on boo boo there so i don't
know i think boo boo might be a denture
man
that's right i don't need you seeing
what i'm drinking
keep your eyeballs out with my cup see
that's that's why the whole red and then
the the plastic of the joint won't wear
out like the foam you know the styrofoam
cups dudes be drinking on the styrofoam
cosmic
nah you and your little and then it'll
be leaking at the bottom now we can't do
the leaky cups
coming over here with your little leaky
cuts and red cups only hate cups only
then you know what type of dude you're
dealing with when he come with the red
cup like oh use a thug and stuff like oh
okay i see where you'd be at
hey yeah you see no brown cups
okay so
me personally i will go with the sunny
delight be honest with you i'm i'm i'm
i'm upset i'm upset right now you know
being that i can't text her let me see
i'm trying to right
you gotta put them i gotta put my phone
sideways
sitting sideways
bring me the juice please this
uh dr pep is disgusting
see dr pepper everybody gave me the bag
then i would have told you it was good
so how do you mean i'm in airplane
don't mess with me i'm not in no damn
airplane mode
wow
it threw my phone in airplane mode and
now it can't take it off
get off
off my damn phone airplane mode
that's absolutely disgusting
oh man i got a whole bunch of stuff now
a whole bunch of calls
how my phone gonna throw itself in
airplane mode
all talking right now
what's going on what's going on
you got a lot of dudes there that's
ready for these fights right now
oh and you know what she know my phone
is broken she gonna text me back like
like
you're gonna text me back
it's the life this is the life
all right hold on let me block this
while she comes down
terrible terrible terrible terrible
times
you gotta pour your drink
properly
and you have so much electronic the way
my day going i don't really need to have
it go that way i don't need just
at the video footage
you won't be putting me on twitter and
showing the video footage of me blowing
up my pc and my rig and everything
everybody wants earl spence to win
yeah you can win a lot of things but um
is it going to happen we'll see later on
tonight
i think he's more focused than he's ever
been though be honest with you 100
i think this is the most focused that
we're going to see him be
and um i honestly expect him to um
to pull it out
uh
feels froggy
it's gonna be crazy oh so yeah vanessa
oh we have um
yo we have an undercard tonight i mean
this is under this undercard is is
pretty underrated um
okay
oh
that's
that's that's the taste that's that's
the taste that i was looking for
you know how uh when you
looking for that sunny delight ice
crushed ice mix with a little hint of uh
of that um
the drink
the the truth serum
yeah that wakes you up right there let
me see
this is going to be a 50 50 fight
i'm gonna give you my prediction right
before the fight to see who comes out
you know warmed up and stuff right now
um oh guys they show olga's right now uh
he looks pretty good he he doesn't even
have his hand wraps now because you know
there's it's just been one fight down to
be honest with you
um
he looks cleaner
than he did when he was ready for the
pacquiao fight and what i'm talking
about cleaner i'm talking about in in in
terms of his his body his his his
physique
um
i think actually this is going to be the
best ooh guys that you're going to see
uh i honestly believe that um
we're going to see the best ooh guys
we're going to see the best spins
that uh we've seen in a long time a
spence actually
more so because remember spence used to
blow up in between fights
uh and when i'm talking about blow up
guys i'm talking about in wait
uh he will go to training camp and his
training camp will be a weight loss camp
anybody knows that you know you're
training and trying to work on things
and implement it but lose weight um
that's more of a detriment to you so he
got away with it for a long time
he said ryan garcia calls out cruz
ryan garcia calls out nobody ryan garcia
had a problem with uh
a cab driver not too long ago and that
went 12 rounds and ryan garcia needs to
focus more on boxing and don't even have
to worry about uh anybody else he don't
need definitely do not call
uh uh pit bull out that pit bull gave
tank all he can handle and that he was a
a late replacement for a fight so um for
rolly and he's actually gonna fight
rolly now so
no ryan garcia no
ryan gossey was gonna fight jojo diaz i
think jojo diaz would have knocked out
ryan garcia
very
easy very easy i think ryan garcia needs
to get back to space
back back to fighting him yeah earl got
his nutritionist and nutritionist is
really good
and he stopped he stopped working with
his last um
conditioning coach and went with another
conditioning coach for this fight
so it's going to be telling to see
what happens now
you know um
with with uh
with how his condition it is later on in
the fight
so
i forgot the guy that he was training
with before that he got all the
knockouts with
that thing was like eight fights he had
that condition in close it was eight
fights eight knockouts and then ever
since he stopped using that conditioning
coach hasn't been any knockouts um earl
hasn't had a knockout in a while pause
pause for what was this
the way i see the fight is that two
things spence winning by in front tko or
spence winning by decision at best i
wouldn't be surprised by
uh
15 12 unanimous decision
i hear you
quite possible
yeah
gamboa isn't what he used to be but
gamble and the same thing with gamboa he
blows up in between fights
he blows up pulse uh
you say
30 pounds in between fights
gamboa's best weight is 135. he's a very
small man in stature so
when when he's he's going to fight right
now
he's it's well past his problem but 50
cent had him
i think they wasted him they put him in
there with uh bug butt and he he caught
bug with a good shot um
but the problem with that fight was he
had a bad leg injury
and then that that thing the same thing
rid its ugly head when he fought tank uh
he was basically fighting tank with one
leg and he still to me put up a great
account of himself when he fought tank
with that uh and i'm talking about
gamboa
with that bad leg so
i don't know
you know everybody's saying that manny
pacquiao was a sheller himself when he
fought oogaz
um
i still thought manny gave a hell of a
count of himself
went uh 12 rounds
uh t-mobile trying to call me no
t-mobile not right now
i told the guy i had a show
so no uh
it's i don't know man to be honest with
you
oh guys we don't know what to make of it
it's so much clouding this fight
because
you know olga's has four losses on his
record right and that's not nothing that
you know to to to sneeze that he has
four losses right
so that means that he went up against a
couple of guys and uh four those guys
actually put their work in
the manny pacquiao fight was a short uh
um
short notice fight you know pacquiao
probably looked at who guys saw the four
losses on his record and was like ah i
got this i don't need to you know put a
hundred percent in
when it comes to uh fighting oogaz and
honestly i think that was to his
detriment um
manny's a higher age
i don't know i don't know what to say
you have spence with the car crashes
and and eye injuries and and
that surrounded him you have all guys
with the four losses and was that a
diminished pacquiao that he fought uh so
you have uh question marks on both sides
going in well
and and
this what i'm hearing a lot of from
people is okay so olga's
is um a southpaw killer
wouldn't that make spence uh orthodox
killer since he has absolutely no losses
and nothing but wins and every time he
fought an orthodox fighter
it was a knockout jose valenzueza
i haven't seen him fight he's fighting
uh francisco vargas um
and i think they're next and then you
have um
cruz versus gamboa
leading up to
the main event so um
i haven't seen this guy fight at all so
this is gonna be my first time seeing
him fight and and what he has to offer
to the fight game
hopefully it's something good you know
but um they were they're making a ring
interest right now so what we have is
we have a
lightweight bout 12 rounds
jose uh valenzuela versus uh francisco
vargas
he looks like a young kid francisco
looks like he's uh in his 30s you know
probably pushing 40. but uh this kid
looks young
yeah yeah
let me see
yeah he fought isaac cruz
last june and that's francisco vargas
i'm saying
uh so
i i don't know
so they did just probably bringing uh
valenzuela through
to um
his next level probably taking him to
the next level so this is probably just
a stepping stone fight i don't know
who's his promoter
yeah
oh see he's a young kid he turns 23
okay so it should be fresh should be
early hopefully we can see at least a
fourth round knockout
i'm doing pretty good uh
i'm
getting this under my feet all right so
check it out so for the channel right
um
for the channel
uh we're gonna have live call it
so everything was you know put together
uh
during the whole period of time thought
about planned about with the team on
what i was going to do with combat
talking combat talk is going to be you
guys going to be able to call in and we
i'm going to be able to interact with
you guys one-on-one
with the fights as we go on so it's
supposed to be like a drink party type
of thing late night eating you up if
you're by yourself you're with me
i'm by myself with y'all so uh that's
that's what i'm looking for that to be
and um
we're gonna have all that stuff so
you're gonna have a number to call
you're gonna have uh you can call the
number
boom we talk and we're gonna be talking
about these fights we're gonna be
talking about the fights live while
they're happening and um i'm probably
gonna do um
uh
mma
when they have big cards even though all
their cards is usually big cards so when
they have big cards i'm definitely going
to do that
so oh a lot of you guys see me sipping
juice out of uh my iron lord's cup
anytime you see me sunday morning that's
juicing it
regular juice regular juice or regular
tea
or something like that but you know late
night fight night if you see the red cup
the red cup go tell you everything the
red cup is gonna definitely
bring you up to speed that it's okay
you're amongst friends we're together
here it's a red cup night
so um
yeah vargas is 27
3 and 2 with 19 ko's
it is what it is right
here to get in this work get this payday
keep it moving payday
he want that payday he want that payday
you oh okay
this is what you're gonna call it all
right so a lot of times in a fight game
you try to figure out how certain dudes
get on the card
this guy got on the car because um
he
his coach this is who god's coach so he
put his man in
sounds awesome king
but i missed the fight night games i
think
the fight night games is coming back
um you have the esba
uh game that's that game looks fantastic
that you know it's all about the
licenses because
it's not like ufc where one governing
body uh governs everybody and then the
the the game can come out all they have
to do is talk to one person
these dudes are individually managed
individually there's no
no one sanctioning body
you know so that's the problem with
boxing
so they have to go and negotiate
individually with each fighter and that
becomes very very expensive
so you know p that's why you know you
get people like floyd in games
and he's going to command a high price
tag
i would love to have a boxing games like
that but you know what you go back to
the back in the old days where you had
one game one one guy you had uh evander
holyfield uh boxing and then you know
you had a bunch of no name dudes and you
just paid for that one license and you
you win what about it did it uh ea paid
a premium dollar for those fight night
games so
that's why you don't see it it's too
much money you know it's too much money
let me see
sounds awesome let me see what i'm
saying let me see
since by tko
in the sixth round
you got high hopes
oh man that's he's he's he's a tall
young kid all right
body shots all right
okay so uh
jose valenzuela is a south
pole all right
nice jab
good good good right hand i mean good
left hand on the lean in
he looks he looks decent he has decent
bounce in his legs
decent movement
tall
he reminds me of um how oscar de la hoya
body used to look like when he first
started
you know he didn't really have a ton of
muscle
he was a sleek look like a swimmer uh he
was able to move in and out of the
pocket throw good uh jabs right hands
yeah yeah this this this looked pretty
good you know
and vargas is trying to move in but the
the kid keeps uh keeping his distance
all right so yeah he has uh venezuela up
against the ropes uh
vargas does but you know he's not really
doing any uh
good work
see venezuela keeps uh going oh oh oh oh
my god what a cat
he knocked in my coat it's a white bang
oh my god
oh oh oh somebody somebody get mild
cassels
[Laughter]
oh my god that
that kid nice i told you he looked like
oscar you riding he remind me of oscar
damn is right damn is right
oh man
you said he hit him with the game pass
select
i told you he kept digging under the
body kept digging under the body and he
brought that um
that left over the top
oh my god yo
you gotta cut the distance on him and
he's so young and so explosive
i wanted to see if he had power and
pause
that kid definitely has some power in
his hands
yo look at that that
wow
wow
that that was definitely
a hundred percent right there
wow
that's that's out of control let me
see yeah yo should die the fact that
he's a left-handed with power like that
that that is um
that's telling man
did that age
jeez
jeez
[Music]
that kid is strong
and he with the pvc
boy you better stay away from these
young boys
yes yo yo they didn't expect they didn't
expect that fight to go that fast they
thought it was good i expected it to go
four rounds
i said four rounds then i see what the
young boy got
oh my god check his blood
[Music]
now
see unlike ryan garcia i know
everybody's looking at ryan garcia like
oh he reminds me of oscar this kid
body wise reminds me of oscar
yeah see he trained with david benavidez
wow
yes yes uh what is he the wbc internet
uh internet
uh continental champion
i gotta see the shot
the shot is crazy he he pause over
and he sweeps it wow
right under the jaw
wow
he swept it over
the lazy right hand the other referee is
so extra
the referee is so extra
yo look at he's swept under the lazy
side of the jaw as official tissues
that's when you figured it out you
figured it out check please that's what
he said check
please sweeping jab
reached under
all right so
the way he leaned out and leaned into
the shot
he didn't even have full talk on his
shot
that's what's crazy about that shot it
wasn't even full talk dad that
this kid is gonna be a problem oh man
he's somebody to watch this yeah
hopefully he can get two more fights in
this year hopefully he can be on the
next uh aerospence undercard um when he
fights but
you know
yeah yeah
hopefully
it it looked like it touched his ankle
like remember roy jones back in the day
touched his ankle it hit the dude in the
mouth
he's showing that the the halo uh
trailer who whoever's watching halo
right now
i gotta watch the latest episode
i'm loving it um
i'm loving what they're doing with it uh
this this is a this is a good year for
halo
and anybody thought about the um
the dlc and why it's called lone wolf if
you're watching the show there's a lot
of lone wolf stuff there
so let me see
oh no um
every every time this this is this is it
um
shout out to graphic god shout out to
dallas the man uh shout out to star uh
we crafted that uh intro i gave them the
ideas of of how i wanted stuff done and
and brought it to them and they put it
together so that's the intro for combat
talk with the king now all right uh
and then you're going to see the intro
for
the new kos show the new koch show uh
you know um
king of the statues that's uh that's
gonna be a live show as well and you
guys are gonna get a chance to uh see
the purple room
um because this is the media room right
and if you saw the red room y'all saw
the red room that i posted on twitter
today
uh
with a little bit of stuff in there uh
you're gonna see the purple room so the
purple room you're going to get a chance
to uh
actually watch me do the live unboxings
inside the purple room
actually this combat talk was supposed
to be in a purple room
but i was doing some stuff i was still
painting before you're doing all types
of crazy stuff then the phone break
ridiculous
he said yeah that was a randy johnson
punch yeah yeah yo what up fun
speculation they in the building this is
crazy everybody pull up with your drinks
watching the fight tuning into the fight
if you can't see the fight i'm gonna
give you blow by bo pause
don't come at me
um but i'm gonna talk to you about the
fight
yeah
wife said send a link
ridiculous
ridiculous women are ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous
she knew
damn well what it was
what show was on or what channel was
so now they talking to this kid and um
they're stretching it out they're trying
to
uh give us you know like because
remember these guys got it there is a
certain amount of promotion that goes
into a fight so a lot of you guys uh
yeah you know oh
i wish it was just all knockouts for
today they will find filler they will
have stuff to talk about because there
are advertisements that has to be done
there's a certain amount of commercials
that they need to run to get their money
back
remember they paying these guys uh the
seats uh the sellout arena
the pay-per-view numbers all that stuff
counts in some form or fashion and so
does the amount of commercials um
in between you know so
and then they also have to promote the
showtime aspect of it because showtime
will give you
uh the road to the fight with the guys
so
yeah i mean but that kid that kid oh
he's a he he's going to be a really good
star i want to see
um
a little bit uh stepped up in
competition that i can see actually more
of his skill set because i think uh
vargas that he fought
vargas was there for payday so anytime
he did get in trouble would be out
no you got your sweet tea ready
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's on
pay-per-view
i don't worry i'll talk
i'll give you uh
the play-by-play to be honest with you
and he checking the guy outside the ring
here we go all right so what we got
going on here we got the charlo brothers
yeah yeah and then we got this uh
this basketball fool i don't even know
why the basketball fool is there
but we got uh both charlo brothers we
got jemele and jamal
uh jamel is going um
for a unification bout uh with castano
and that's going to be for undisputed in
their weight division
and jamal is fighting um
one of his mandatories
uh
i think jamal could have did a lot more
to be put in line to be um
canelo's are mandatory but uh canelo
would have just docked him like he did
before so i don't think that's um that
wouldn't you know
actually um
advisable so it's whatever
that was a good fight
uh
jamel
uh versus uh castano
that was a good fight i thought that
castano put in a lot of the early work
and
i thought jamal actually had a lot of
the the telling shots
so
it was kind of justified in in in the
outcome
also so jamel has the
mounties hat so anybody's um canadian he
has a canadian mount he's had
and jamal is right next to his brother
twins could you imagine having two
successful children that are actually
twins that are in the same
um profession
that actually
uh excel
how proud are the parents i mean that's
that's kind of crazy right i mean well
i'm talking as a as a father
you know um the level of pride that you
get is of your children's success and
that and
those kids have succeeded at the the
highest level at the highest level in in
their chosen profession
athletic and and that's a hard that's a
school of hard knocks when that ain't no
no easy no easy task i mean to get in
there to stare down your fears and you
know to make it through training camp
and and to into to actually push through
it's like
you know you see these nba players right
you see these uh uh football stars to to
persevere through the hundreds and the
thousands of uh other athletes that are
trying to get into your profession to
make your name
that's incredible that's incredible and
you know
boxing there is no team there's no god
to lean on excuse me
when you're having a bad day when you're
having a bad day it's your bad day
now you have a corner that can help pull
you through but
they can only do so much you got to be
in there you got to move your hands you
got to move your feet you know you got
to have you got to think you got to see
you know and you got to conquer that
fear
fear is the worst
fears the worst thing that you can have
when you're in the ring
what's going on
only on xbox what's going on
the klitschko brothers
i love those guys and um shout out to
the ukraine fight fighting as hard as
they are
um respect
but we we saw their pedigree from their
fighters that that made it over
you know um alexander usak um
you know the klitschko brothers
um
uh what's what's
lomachenko
you know respect to to uh the hard
workers
they're the blue collared um
countrymen
so we we we see that
what what type of uh individuals that
they make and they've been live on the
front stage you know ecliptic
klitschko's they
went from sports to politics
and and definitely
early on they excelled from
from being doctors
to sports
and they've excelled in every level
of any endeavor that they achieve to go
to
ridiculous fantastic stuff
i i would never want to see the the
charlo brothers fight and i never wanted
to see the klitschko brothers fight
i don't i don't even like to see friends
fight
you know but um
let's be real
bud fought up sean porter and that's his
friend
any time that i fight you and you beat
me and the next day i'm on your podcast
come on man
something stinks
i just felt some stunk be honest with
you fight was cold early father throws
in the towel and then you're gonna talk
about uh
oh i didn't like how he trained in camp
come on man
trained in camp really
that's what was gonna go over here
or is we could both make some money we
could just go out there and beat each
other up for a look man anyway
i want to see bud fight somebody fight
somebody in that division not just uh
run around talk about i want earl spence
no get in there fight somebody in that
division stop playing around
okay here we go
we got the
pit bull cruise
versus gambo and gamboa was that dude
back in the days right
okay so earl hand is getting wrapped
right now so um
so right now they putting the the hand
wrap on once that first knockout went
down with the last fight then they
accelerated their program they they uh
called them up you know
the phone call goes through and they
tell them uh
you know to give them a countdown give
them an eta and tell them to start
getting uh ready because there's
different levels of getting ready when
you inside uh
the green room in the back uh getting
your stuff together so right now they're
going through the show time joint with
earl
and um
he's still with brian custer so he's
hitting the
right cost
brian custer's a heavyweight this is
ridiculous
let me see let me see
man listen it's it's
bud budding's stupid
but no those boys hit heavy if he if he
mess around and get in there with keith
thurman can't get to keith thurman body
which we all know is keith thurman's
kryptonite
he said are you so we got a super chat
from laura cognito
what a guy are you sending uh to my fun
to fund my phone because my phone is
dead
until i can get another one
it says sup king first time caller long
time listener why 50 cent don't rock
with gamboa no more thanks [ __ ]
50 cent used to promote uh yoku's gamboa
and it was it was a thought of a good
idea right so this is when
floyd lied to 50
and said that they both was going to
work on getting tmt promotions
together that's when you know 50 cent
had these headsets and that's when 50
cent did f and vodka and 50 cent was uh
putting that movies uh the tv shows
together power he was doing that stuff
so 50 cent was still getting g unit
money g unit sneakers still had the
vitamin water money and he's still doing
this stuff so he's moving up he's he's
getting up higher he started hanging
around floyd and then they came with the
idea boom we're gonna do um
uh we're gonna promote together get this
business together um again you're
talking about millionaires
and and trying to be billionaires
um there's gonna be some friction there
you know i don't think a lot of dudes
work together properly so what happened
was 57 went out and started getting a
bunch of fighters like mickey bay uh
gamboa and a couple other fighters he
had he had a lot of he had a good stable
a good stable of 10 fighters
and
uh floyd went away to jail floyd went
away to jail he came back different i
really in my head think that has
something to do with miss jackson be
honest with you 100
uh why those dudes
had a big falling out they were uh
besties for a minute and um again uh
something happens and nine times out of
ten what happens with besties what
happens with dudes usually is a girl um
so yeah they had fallen out and that's
how gamboa
you know 50 cent is not a promoter but
if he's working with somebody in that
space he can definitely promote he can
definitely get the shows on so he was
doing that
with floyd and floyd actually you know
kind of dissed him and uh did his own
thing
lennon led and all that stuff because
floyd honestly realized that he didn't
need 50 cent for anything
um you know 50 cent celebrity is not a
boxing celebrity so that's when they had
they ripped so that's why he doesn't do
uh promote gamboa no more but gamboa is
still
ushered into the pvc so that answers
that question
salute to you king glad you decided to
stream the fight night and spend some
time with the realm appreciate you
for what you do i'm 100
that's uh
skin walker the jedi
thank you so much for the 5 super chat
that goes the the fixed king
fixed
the king's phone fun
um
yo
oh man i uh trust me i i was talking
about this with the guys for a long time
you know um going through a whole lot of
stuff in the last year some change uh
puts a lot of things in in perspective
and
i i do fight nights every big fight i
sat there i sit there and watch the
fights you know um and remember i was
doing combat talking i'll give you a
combat talk and my prediction for the
fights and then i'll talk about it on
the show
um
but then there's a whole big thing
missing right the whole big thing
missing is us getting that conversation
in
and
i just decided just to have the
conversation with you oh for all those
people talking about you know i was
wearing coats
because i was cold no i was and i was
doing it just to piss people off in
spaces so tomorrow i have another coat
on remember 30 days of coach isn't up
you know it's just it's only four days
in a month so you gotta count how many
months i gotta wear a different coat
every weekend there's only four times so
i tried my best to get in all these
coats let me see
let me see that's cog and see do you
feel
how do you feel about mike tyson
wanton spence and jamal the fight um
they're not brothers
i don't care if i'm your friend some of
the best friends in the in the world is
for um maurice brockler blocker versus
um
what was this guy's name oh my god well
anyway they fought
and uh oh simon brown versus uh maurice
blocker go watch that fight he knocked
his best friend out that was his best
friend
but um like mike said if you my brother
if you my friend we let us get money
don't close off no cash just because
we're friends let's go get some money
together let's go do this thing so
uh yeah jamal versus um spence
that won't happen um
excuse me because derek james uh matt uh
is uh the coach of both of them so
derek james will have to pick who he
wants to
uh coach for that fight because you
can't coach both of them
right so that will cause a rift that
will make him
lose money
lose
uh respect that's like having your kids
fight so
derek james will have to choose and then
with derrick james would be the smart
thing for derek james to do is just not
train either one of them
and i don't think either one of them
want that because i think they have a
level of comfortability when it comes to
derrick james um so no um
i don't see that fight ever happening at
all you know and that for that reason
alone
anything else but if it was me
let's get this money together stop
playing
cool didn't either let me see this sir
your cogs they're saying this why is
activision yo what's going on
when is the next kos show next kos show
is crazy first of all y'all didn't even
see the intro for the next kos show it's
coming up
um i got a ton of statues that i didn't
even unbox yet i got statues on the
sides right over here that i didn't even
unbox i got statues that's coming in i
didn't even unbox yet but you you're
gonna see uh the red room in the
beginning of the intro then you're gonna
see a lot of my statues in that whole
thing shout out to graphic god that's
working on it um the intro was done
again by uh graphic god putting together
the visuals uh you have drum star on the
beat you know check out drum stuff if
you don't know he's in the credits of
the beginning of the video and also do
me a favor and hit up your man dallas
demand yo
dallas is definitely one dude that i
like to work with i like to stay working
with the same people like de niro sean
labre graphic guard all these dudes that
um i work with
on a lot of things i like to keep that
in family i like to you know stay
working with people so as we grow they
grow so if any of y'all need any work
anything
done any help go to graphic guard go to
dallas go to drum star get your stuff
done from them they charge uh reasonable
prices on things and they work with you
100
so check those dudes out but yeah kos is
coming and in this in his pause
the way that i do kos
i'm going to get
everybody that participates you see how
many people we have we have 27 people
here watching right now right
and
we had a little bit more earlier um
gamble was coming out right now
yo
i'm gonna make sure
that everybody that participates
gets a chance to go home
with a statue
like these
all right ship to your house so you know
no extra charge is going to be it's
going to be dope it's going to be dope
as hell
no there's any crackling audio
let me know
shouldn't be
this microphone is definitely beautiful
it's a wonderful thing
anybody getting crackling audio let me
know
all right so we have gamboa
and he's up there oh he's ready
well i don't know gamboa looks nice so
isaac cruz is coming out right now
i don't know
he has all the mexican sombrero you know
when you ask for fame and then fame
actually shows up
i think he
and then this is isaac cruz here
isaac pitbull cruz the guy though when
he fought tank
um remember he was a last minute
replacement for rolly
rolly romero
and i think
he's
soaking up the newfound stardom that he
got from um
you hear a little crackle i don't know
where that could be from
it can't be is it is it is it
let me see
how it sounds
let me know let me know
does um
javonte have a good reason to be upset
with floyd
floyd made him
a millionaire
i can never be upset with you
if you recognize my talent and you put
your star
behind me to make me a millionaire
um
let me see
evan p with the 1999
super chat my favorite
iron lord the watch thank you brother
obi wan of the xbox culture
that's what's up
the lord because let me see
gotta click it
see this is why i love
what you're gonna call it uh brian
law bro soros
to the playstation haters the man who
looks into the mind of phil spencer
what's good king
at work watching
your stream thank you brother thank you
for watching the stream i do appreciate
it um it'll be a lot of other things
that will be actually
fixed and stuff in here so you have
isaac pitbull cruz coming up right now
floyd
floyd is always going to be able to
chase his bag and capitalize on the star
status when you hit your your wagon to
somebody
that is a superstar in a sport that you
chose to be
a fighter in
you have to take certain things
um but this is negotiations his contract
is up his value is higher
so
there's no part of gratitude when it
comes to
they made money already right so
there's no gratitude with that part
you're looking to establish your future
when floyd left bob aaron and he paid to
get out of his contract a bob aaron made
floyd a millionaire right so
did he was he beholding to bob arum
no he wasn't um and it did get kind of
messy same thing with bud
when he left but
bob aaron
the difference between all of that stuff
the difference between all of that
floyd may tank a pay-per-view star
bob didn't make uh floyd a pay-per-view
star and bob didn't make uh bud a
pay-per-view star
so
um
tank is a pay-per-view star his last
three fights was on pay-per-view and
it's all due to tmt promotions so
they're in negotiations right now
hopefully they can come out of it on
other side um
i think uh without the guiding hand of
floyd and and the pvc with al haymon
and um tmt promotions i don't think uh
tank can actually
win if he has the next four fights i
don't think he wins the next four fights
i think he wins out of the next four
fights without floyd he wins probably
three of them or two of them
because he's going to get himself in in
deep waters he fights lomachenko i don't
care how much power you have lomachenko
is going to box circles around you
he's going to
for the get
intercontinental lightweight
championship
introducing you first on my right hand
red white and blue
he said it's my beard drawing now
it's stupid yeah i think it's fake beef
i think it's fake beef to promote that
fight that they had up there for weeks
at the barclay center that didn't sell
out so yeah i think it's fake beef be
honest with you
that's floyd mayweather's promotional
tactic he's been doing fake beef for
years
to actually enhance his portfolio
they're talking about gamboa right now
so again boys being introduced
puerto rican um no cuban cuban flag
sorry
here we go
all right isaac pitbull cruz 22
two losses one draw 15
by way of knockout
has gamboa become the stepping stone
for up in comments
dear god
let's hope not
let's hope not
if
if he knocks out this i cruise right now
this is going to be the quickest fastest
little rise to stardom that you've ever
seen in your life
let me see
ryan garcia is not the real deal to be
honest with you
sovereign what's going on they they're
actually doing a fun my phone
shout out to you with the 20 super chat
let me see uh
aka
kids 19.
yeah
now ryan garcia is he has to prove a lot
to me
yeah i think i think he is
all right so um oh
all right so pitbull cruel runs across
the ring and uh he swings on uh gamboa
gamboa uh is uh against the ropes and
he's throwing jabs it looks like oh my
god oh my god gamboa is getting knocked
out in the first round
cruz just hit him with a left right
oh
my
he's done
he's done he's done
he is done
he's done he's holding right now for
dear life boy
he's smothering the shots
isaac cruz the smothering the shot step
back jab your way in
jab your way in nice and easy jab your
way in he's not doing it you jab your
way in go right back to what got you
there
there you go bring it under the bottom
damn boa is on queer street legs ain't
looking right
[Laughter]
come on isaac slide in slide
see that's that's the problem he he
he got overzealous when he caught um
gamble with the left right
oh man
it's it's it's
it's a hunting it's a hunting season
so get over here
oh my god
oh my god he hit him on the side of his
head and made the spit go to the fifth
row
oh my god imagine going to the fight and
get spit on by somebody that's in the
middle of the ring so how did you get
spitting your eye the guy in the middle
of the ring i had enough
oh man he pulls his head back when he
pulls out a fight and uh clinches
it's just a hold fest right now damn bo
is holding on him trying to act like he
ain't holding on him
it's not a good look
this is
absolutely disgusting
gambo is jabbing so gamboa's head is a
little bit clearer um
isaac cruz
he smothered all the shots and he let uh
gamboa hold them
and and and this this is this is not
good this is not good so i uh i
isaac cruz uh keeps throwing the the jab
and throwing the overhand right
but he's not actually working
gamboa
so you know yeah
he allowed gamboa to
survive the round there's 15 seconds
left in the round he would have got
knocked out in the first round had
uh
isaac cruz uh take a a half step back
and shoot the right hand
but he see he's he's missing with his
shots he's being wild he's exerting a
ton of energy and he's going to give um
gamboa the ability to come back in this
fight
and
i'ma tell you right now
you don't want a veteran to get his sea
legs and you get tired
what up craig
[Laughter]
you think jake paul is the truth
you wild crazy
see
then ball went to grab
he's supposed to he's supposed to be
knocked out cold
that's it right there the right hand
said
he's so stupid
all he had to do was close the gap and
stay close
but there it is he's back to his
energetic self
jab
low squat
okay so you hit and gamble see now gambo
is fighting back
i told y'all before don't let a old
veteran
survive take your best shot
and then get to get a chance to put in
his work
oh yo now cam bola has him up against
the ropes
putting in work
this this doesn't make any sense
literally gamboa was out on his feet in
the first round
and
and isaac cruz
uh
he could have punched himself out to be
honest with you swinging as well is he
doing i mean he's young
he's strong you don't expect that to
happen
but again
i've seen stranger things now um okay so
gambo is back on his jab so
how do you stop an a russian truck right
you sit there you jab his jab and you
move gamboa's has um
good uh head movement good waist
movement
lateral movements not really there that
much he used to be known for his
footwork
but he's soft in the middle you can tell
by his gut by his uh his belt pulled up
all right um
the way he walks away from uh
the combat
you know um you can tell he's saving his
legs for the later rounds
i i think
okay so it's clear to say right now that
uh gamboa head is clear right
and
the jab right hand he's working it
he's working it he's working it jab
right hand
isaac cruz needs to settle down
the only way he's going to
catch gamboa
again is by setting him up and he's not
setting up anything he's walking in
without a jab he's swinging wildly
trying to land a shot and he's he he
keeps going to um gamboa's body
the the problem with that is
you know oh and gamboa keeps sliding in
sneaky overhand rights
i don't know man this this
this could be a uh at least a 12-round
mess
for izak cruz
you know and
if he actually
is he's isaac
if if he actually wants to end this
fight early all he has to do is jab his
way in
touch him to the body then go for the
the heavy shots finally caught him
finally caught him
but he punches him while he's down on
the floor so all right so we got gamboa
that went down right now and he finally
caught him because he finally jabbed his
way in and then shot the left
but that was at the end of the round
good round isaac stole the round gambol
was running around up until that point
but again
dear god
something happened
something happened
when something happened he's he's
complaining about something
oh okay straight to the body boom right
to the face straight to the body right
to the jaw
okay
and he was overwhelming him with shots
so
he was going from the body all the way
up to the head from the body all the way
up to the head
good good stuff
let me see let me see
oh he knocked him out
so he jabbed him really quick and then
went to a very fast left right
combination and it was the left to the
body right to the head okay so again
gamble is up and
isaac is all over him going straight to
the body going to the head oh my god
he's putting in shots oh man paul gamble
gamboa is fodder
fodder
oh no his lace ain't good
he should not make it out of this round
he should not make it out of this round
oh my god round three and this is the
the fight before the main event
here we go
oh
um that's a hell of a body shot
gamboa just got hit with a body shot he
just threw isaac on the floor
this has turned into a tackle fest
but isaac is young enough to actually
get up with no ill effects
um gamboa looks weak
punch drunk
right hand off the top of the dome from
isaac to gamboa
left uppercut
all right
oh man that shot would have definitely
took gamboa out all right so gamboa is
backtracking while uh
isaac is uh
actually attacking right now they're in
the clinch referee breaks them up
and then you got a
a back to another clinch
i don't like the fact how isaac smothers
his work you know
the jabs his corner needs to teach him
how to jab his weight in
i'm sure that he thinks that his style
is uh perfected mike tyson perfected
that style that peekaboo style with a
jab the jab was up jab that came up that
actually set everything up
and that's the problem
he has no jab
everything he relies on is hooks
and uppercuts see he he leans
and he throws a lot of hooks
that's not good
he's not going to have any longevity he
walks into somebody that has a serious
jab
that's why tank was able to beat him
has a jab
and tank has the same amount of power
jab
oh man
i don't know how the hell gamboa is is
standing up
the fight is definitely fire
this is definitely a a worthy um
fight before
the main event
isaac keeps smothering his work man i
would be so furious with him in the
corner
whenever he came back because everything
he does is like a leaping left hook
that leads to a clinch
and he has to understand he's initiated
gamboa lays this shot he's done he
should not be there
he
you definitely should have landed
something that can definitely finish the
fight but you didn't you haven't done it
so you know they're sitting in the
corner and they they're rubbing them
around down pause
and then telling him you know get his
timing down
this guy is in survival mode
i hope i can hit uh isaac cruz corner
tell him jab your way in make it easy
work
let me see
let me see
left hook straight off the off the rip
caught him on the jaw and he caught
gamboa when he was exchanging with a
left hook
that's not cool
that's not cool
so you know gamboa goes down
and flips him over
that's not cool
you know he can land it hurt herself
oh my god this yo it's like the
beginning of every round isaac cruz has
this ton of energy by sitting in the
corner and he just rushes out across the
ring and he catches
gamboa with a left hook another left up
other uppercut
and it's uh
gamboa's pushing him up against the
ropes
pushing him literally
not uh not fighting him up against the
ropes he's pushing him up against the
ropes
referee has his work cut out for him
this evening
separating both of them
but again there we go
there we go
so again bo is jabbing them
but the the longer see the problem with
gamboa he throws his jab from his
stomach
and he shoots it straight out right he's
leaving all this open here
so if you're shooting it from your
stomach you're leaving this open and
what does isaac does he comes over the
the lazy jab with a right
so all left hook so
it's it's
it's stupid
so there we go he's uh he has a gamboa
in the corner again
stalking him stalking him
no job no jab coming in he jabs here and
there
only has a a touch a range finder
but no actual physical um jab to set up
work
bad footwork
both his feet is together
so that's why gambo is able to survive
uh his fundamentals is bad
uh
football uh cruz isaac cruz uh
fundamentals is bad gamboa still has
good fundamentals
but um he's older
he's uh past his prime
and he's more of a gatekeeper now to uh
the upper echelon of uh of fighting so
he's he's more or less a name
opposed to a good uh a good um contender
to be honest with you
former champion has a good name
that's all he has right now he doesn't
have
anything that can keep this guy at bay
man and and it's so sad
hit him now with another left hand and
drop gamboa again
so far this is four times gamboa has
gone down
and um that that by far was the worst
one so far
okay oh oh okay
okay
round four eight seconds left
isaac is trying to end it
oh my god
nope
gamboa has
survived
another round is that a good thing or is
that a detriment
sometimes you don't need to survive good
god
what's going on
5z that's my dude
get a stretcher out man just put out a
whole lazy boy for the dude
oh my god
the left hook was murderous absolutely
murderous
that was oh my god that was absolutely
murderous let me see let me see if i can
get this little
king emoji out
can i get it off pause
is it this one
all right they started again
he's taking a ton of shots i would i
would not let him keep fighting
be honest with you i guess his corner
don't like him
but he's still in there
wouldn't it be crazy
if he beats cruz he knocks crews out
that would be nuts all right so
isaac is is doing what he does
falling in behind his shot
throws the left hook
throws the right hand falls in behind
his shot
and if if
if you're a good fighter
or a fighter that is actually there to
actually win
um he has flaws in his style that you
can you can exploit
like he's acceptable to the overhand
right oh that's it man
that's it
that's it he hit this dude with the
overhand right here gamble with over him
right and killed him
the fight is over the referee loves him
the referee said the hell to the no
can't always talk about
let me keep it moving
go sit down someplace
shout out to pitbull cruz
getting knocked out um
that that's that's the best knockout his
career
excuse me
that is the best
knockout of his career
shout out to isaac cruz
that that was that was
he did something that tank couldn't do
he did something that bud didn't do
he beat gamboa from pillar to post
from the beginning
and yeah they fought gamboa at different
stages of
of gamboa's uh professional career
he kind of got him at his uh tail end of
his career so
it's uh predictable exactly what should
have happened so
uh shout out to him for going out and
doing exactly what he's supposed to do
to an old veteran
uh that's uh gatekeeping up to the upper
echelon so yeah
ryan garcia
do not call this dude out
you won't make it out of four rounds
with isaac
cruz stay away from him until you take
this boxing game very serious
that's kind of crazy good fight
good fight good fight good fight bravo
he he he did exactly what he was
supposed to do
what's up what's that what's that
it's wild to finish um
i think
when your heart is out of it and you
start talking about retirement
then you're done
and um
that's exactly what he was doing
i do think wild is finished i do think
wilder doesn't need to come back wilder
secured the bag got exact everything
that he wanted from the tyson fury fight
he got he got the last fight that he
wanted
and what happened tyson fury knocked him
out
so again um
you know stuff like that happens
so
it is what it is it's nothing that i can
say about it
he
he felt
when when when you when you take the
heart of a lion
and and believe you me
he has nothing else to say about tyson
fury after that third fight
after he he gave it his all but still
came up short
um when you take the heart of a lion
what else tyson fury needs to prove to
him tyson fury will always be that
sailing there for himself
was he gonna go fight aj and knock out
aj what is that gun prove nothing
so
that that he's he's at a disadvantage to
be honest with you because when the guy
you can't beat is the guy
then
what happens next right
that's
it's kind of messed up it's not like the
guy that you're fighting on the way up
you lost to him a couple of times but
it's some way that you can avoid him to
get up to the championship and move
further
he will always be his end game
he already reached the precipice three
times you know so he was lucky to get a
decision the first fight
and
listen had he had they counted that
first fight how they supposed to and
tyson fury would have gotten knocked out
he would have never fought him a second
time he damn sure and never got to a
third fight he would have never fought
him a second time and he would have got
to the aj fight so we're talking about a
whole different scenario of happenings
right
so
you got to understand uh deontay wilder
is he
has no options
and if y'all say okay is uh
joshua to fight joshua
then what
going right back to tyson fury
no i don't see that i don't see that as
a good option
yeah gamboa needs to retire
yeah i still think he won the first
fight yeah i honestly believe that he
won the first fight
but again
you know we are not the judges so
if if you only go on by the knock downs
and the in the swing rounds and he gave
those to wilder you still got to come up
with a draw because tyson fury
showed you throughout the whole fight he
was beating him from pillar to post
i mean
you got to be
you got to be non-partisan you got to be
neutral when it comes to the fight game
right you can have your only favorites
all you want but if you're seeing
something call it a spade tyson fury won
all the rounds that mattered
uh deontay wilder won the rounds that he
knocked him down in and he won maybe one
or two swing rounds and got him a draw
in the first fight
the second fight
they said he was cheating he was
cheating in the first fight and cheating
in the second fight then why the hell
didn't you stop it why didn't the hell
if you're the champion why the hell
didn't you have stuff put in place um
but we're seeing
why right um the tmk
manager
and some mob ties and some other stuff
like that
leads to that
and um then the third fight
come on man
no
he he should retire unless uh unless
something happens to tyson fury if tyson
fury goes away then he can come back
because it has been proven that he
cannot beat that man
if one one fight you're lucky to get a
draw the second fight you get knocked
out in the third fight you get knocked
out come on now let it go
let it go
you ain't gonna beat me up that many
times for me to say
we got we got i don't like money that
much to get beat up all that many times
we good
so we going to the main event now
and um
shout out to raquino yo i'm sorry i
can't tweet at you i can't text you
usually during this period of time i
have a ton of people that i'm texting
and i'm talking to
my phone is broken
i put in for my whatchamacallit
hopefully i will have a phone before i
get to pax but
my phone is broken it just
some freak accident was on the table
just fell off the table
because i was moving the table over and
it felt on a piece
of a corner and crack right there
you don't think tyson fury's a
legitimate champion you're kind of crazy
if he got lucky
then what did you call the second fight
in the third fight
oh i don't have no apple phone
i don't do that i don't do iphones
no this is a samsung galaxy uh
uh 20
ultra 5g whatever super smash brother
phone whatever
so
they're going to give me another one of
these
and
they was like oh you can upgrade so this
didn't let me give you the hustle right
they said uh get the customer care you
can get that and then we have a trade-in
upgrade option
so
for me to get a 2022 phone
right and then also if i open up another
line i'm gonna open up another line and
close my my wife's line and just give
her the new phone you get two phones
right
so
um
i get this phone gotta pay a hundred
dollars to get this phone again then i
can trade it in
then i trade it in and they give me a
brand new phone
stupid
absolutely stupid instead of just taking
my phone that's under insurance take the
insurance due to deductible and just
give me the brand new phone tomorrow
while i'm at the store
that makes more sense right here give me
your broken phone it's under warranty we
give you uh give me the 100 deductible
and just pick out your phone and go
about your business that way i don't
have no issues this week i have all my
information like yo when i go in my
media coverage my media stuff everything
man the hell with these phones
with these phones these phones break you
are broken
my uber everything i'm jacked up now
i used to have apple back in the days
oh i used to have the itunes stuff i
used to have all that stuff when when it
first came out i didn't do the
blackberry stuff i went from the razer
flip phone straight to the iphone
and then um from that i went to galaxy
because i i saw a lot of galaxy stuff
and i was into that
and this stuff was pretty good
excuse me
so now
but ever since then you see the thing is
if i jump into an iphone now
all the world that i built up here
is gone
so that's basically starting from
scratch so i'm i'm damn sure i'm not
doing that
you know they have they have the pluses
and minuses both of them do you know
uh so
it's it's either all it is it's where
you where you're at you know where did
you build your your digital uh imprint
that's the same thing with playstation
and xbox dudes a lot of times you've
built such of a digital library inside
the playstation ecosystem that you can't
switch over all you can do is just add
them you know add another console over
um and the same thing with the the xbox
you
could uh
put the the world
all on your xbox and
you can't really switch over to the
playstation because your digital
footprint is
all xbox you know so
that's how it goes
he said google got you android
everything
i damn sure won't get no google phone
i don't i don't like how those phones
look right now
i don't like how they look right now
i think they're two years away from
being uh fantastic
hey yo y'all see that uh
that a scarlet witch i never even talked
about that scarlet witch nate they
haven't i did the unboxing on dcx i
haven't even talked about that scholar
what she has that's in the corner she
looks dope right
fantastic statue
all right so we're up against the main
event right now guys
all right so we have ugas right now
who's um
right he's um
getting warmed up inside the back
beautiful
beautiful beautiful
now okay so i did say
leading up to this i said who i think
was going to win
i think i i have um
spence by 12-round decision
i see oogaz
working very hard
i see oogaz putting in enough work in
this fight
um
i think he's a little i think oh god's a
little bit faster than spence
all right so as far as warmed up i see
uga is more warm
and
more sweating than spence
spence looks dry
so here we go
we're getting ready for the main event
and um
i'm gonna tell everybody
take a bathroom break get ready
they're about to go get busy
so the betting line is and
earl spence is minus 600 that's the
money line uh
oh guys it's plus 425
a winner by uh tko or ko
um the betting is on uga said uh plus
1200
and
tko for uh
expenses plus uh
240.
this is this kind of fight ends in the
draw it's at plus 18
fight ends in the first 60 seconds is
that plus 10 000
of course is that plus 10 000 dollars
because and none of these dudes has ever
done anything like that
yeah yeah i used to box
um
uh golden gloves atlanta uh champion um
yeah that's that's that that's a crazy
story i was supposed to go uh to all in
norris um boxing gym in in texas which
is absolutely crazy
uh
and i was sponsored by
shabazz
on
116th street um
it's kind of crazy so it's it's that's a
wild story to tell at some point in time
that story of be told but um yeah yeah
i was a
a bit of a thing
all right i sparred with shannon briggs
um
uh
mitch green
was a good friend of mine iron barkley's
a good friend of mine
uh superman aaron davis is a good friend
of mine rest in peace pineal whitaker
he's a cool friend
um
a lot of stuff a lot of stuff
a lot a lot of stuff a lot of stuff i've
always been around boxing always love
boxing
um
that's that's like uh
besides comic books and all this other
stuff that's like my first passion you
know
that stuff uh
because it's it's it's
it's the biggest gladiator sport it's
the most mono imano is the most uh
you showing exactly what you have i'm
not taking anything away from any other
sports but i'm just saying that whole
uh fact that it's up against what you
work put it what what work you put in
and the results that you're looking for
and when you're going in you're putting
up the
the the challenge
against the dude that's in front of you
it's the ability to break that guy's
will that's in front of you which is
probably my ultimate
uh addiction to the sport
because
if that guy is on equal footing with you
then
it's all about you dominating that
person's will
and that's kind of crazy paul
that's yo
it's a sold out stadium
at dallas cowboys stadium
shout out to earl spence man listen
first of all
to to sell out dallas stadium
and you have oh guys which is not a
pay-per-view draw
who's the man man that that dude's the
man right now
uh i gotta see if canelo can sell out
cowboys stadium
but right now earl spence has sold out
cowboy stadium man
i want people to sell out cowboy stadium
is actual damn cowboys
so
we're getting to the main event
i hope everybody got their popcorn ready
this is about to be what it is right
here
when you have
a guy that can escape cuba
and a guy that can escape death
and they meet head up in the ring
who do you got
yes i'm a fan of ufc and yes ufc is
comparable to boxing any combat sport
where you could put manual manual
against each other
yes
yes i honestly believe
that they are on equal footing um
i remember when mma used to be
uh well miss martial arts used to be
uh you have uh boxing versus karate
and all
taekwondo
versus muay thai i remember when it was
that like that
and
they would put different disciplines
against different disciplines and that
was the hook
um but now
it's it's all around they all around
skilled
um
and grappling
and and striking and and and so on uh i
think miss martial arts ufc in
particular you know
bellator they have earned their space in
combat
i don't think they get paid enough
uh i i think the level of brutality when
you when you're mixing knees and elbows
uh to strike uh people
i think um
financially they should be compensated
in the way that boxes are compensated
not all boxes are compensated
at the highest level either you know so
but i don't think the the financial pull
is
good enough for them so all right we
have ooh guys coming out right now
this is this is this has been very fast
guys we have very good knockouts in the
undercard
it's 11 35 we're pulling up to the good
fight
all hell iop
gerald mack what's good baby
we about to get busy right now so
everybody don't went to the bathroom
everybody ready
all guys is hype i respect that i
respect that hispanic blood in you baby
i respect that fire that's in your soul
he he deserves this he deserves this he
went out there and put her on the line
you got ooh guys with the upset see mac
that's what's up
you must be a bug crawford fan
[Laughter]
that's that playstation in you let it
out
jesus yo the walk
from the dressing room to the ring is
like a
like a mile
um all boxes have to do is worry about
one aspect um
mixed martial arts you have to worry
about
foot feet uh
elbows shins
knees
back hands spinning back hands there's
so much stuff that you have to worry
about right and then when you're on the
floor the level of grappling that goes
on into that
um man listen um
but then you have a high level boxer
that high level box that has uh
learned how to get the knockout despite
the fact that he's only using his hands
right
um as apples versus oranges i said they
on equal footing as far as
um
being respected
if you have a high level uh mma fighter
versus somebody in a high level boxer
versus somebody
the the results should be equal so um
i i can't pick the two be honest with
you and my love and my biases is gonna
tell me to pick boxing at all times
because i have witnessed the greatest uh
sugar ray robinson
uh i've i've i'm in love with the sweet
science
you know you you ever see
i like um
the way i'm moving a ring is absolutely
crazy it's startling to see right so
when i see people exhibited that level
of uh technical know-how and that power
of command
um
no
it's something to behold but then i see
anderson silva
and i think i that between anderson
silva and horse
gracie those are the two greatest
mma fighters i've ever seen in my life
anderson silva and i've seen john bones
jones and i've seen a lot of these other
guys spencer's walking out right now
and who he has rap and form
i don't know he has some rapper that's
walking out with him right now but um
again uh
me personally i'm always gonna pick
boxing
i
it's the level of footwork the level of
head movement the level of
awareness the spatial awareness you know
nah man it's for me that's just for me
let me see what's up what's up
he said there how you know
he's a butt on the gym ryan
payroll yo
what up gds
getting stuff done
thank you thank you for appreciating my
response sir
thank you for repeating we appreciate my
response
but i've seen some crazy stuff from him
and me man like um
conor mcgregor
a beautiful fighter right
but uh
uh that with that boy uh that wrestled
with those those grizzly bears as a kid
naga made off jesus
that dude
when i saw him run to the top rope and
jump off the top rope and do an eagle
kick on somebody head
oh god in the boy that is a dude
that has no f's to give in his lifetime
he did it off the top rope after
fighting
so now
all right so
i just noticed something
with spence walking up to the ring he
took a second he paused he looked up at
the ring to look inside the ring
now listen
fighting at home
is different
all right trying to impress some people
that that's that's there is different
right
i think spence knows that he's in for uh
one hell of a battle right now to be
honest with you
i think spence really knows
that this dude right here that he's
about to battle
is really um
that uh
that real deal situation
so um
oh god i hope i hope he's ready
i hope he's ready
but he's talking
he's moving both guys seen joel
the worst part about boxing is that they
always got to be a loser
two guys walk in and the result is
always gonna show up at the end of the
night
so um
i pick uh spence
by
12-round decision
can it go before then can he get it
can he get a knockout in the 10th round
[Music]
first team in the uk baby
let's go
yeah
i had a pressure on spins for sure man
that is no lie added pressure on spins
for sure
all right so
what's the what's the reach errol uh
earl is the 72 old guys is 73 and a half
um
olga's is 35 earl is the younger man
but then you got the car accident
tonight and should be ready to see how
old you how old can you be getting
flipped out of the car
that gotta that gotta make you 37 they
got to make you 37 years old because
i'll get flipped out the car right now
i'm automatically 75 i'll be 75 years
old right after that
i don't know i don't know we about to
see something
something got to give
somebody got to give the lights going
out
jim lampley is here
he's in the background
back from his hbo days
all right earl looking like earl right
now
here we go here we go earl looking like
earl right now
cut that little mouse tail off the back
of his head good
houston stand up
your boy out here cuba stand up your boy
out here
let's go let's go
ej got that uh neon purple
and neon green
looking like he's gamma radiated
had to go with the hulk
says
like seafood
he definitely he definitely was on some
sifu
he definitely woke up out their sleep
was
20 years older
let me see
[Music]
oh so what i'm sipping on
i told you guys at first they started
off with the dr pepper joint right
didn't work out too good i told you it's
going to slide some effing
inside that joint and um
but then uh you know shout out to 50
cent um
but my go-to always crushed ice
uh
sunny delight
hood drink red cup
with the twizzle
a little bit of effort usually it's
sorak though usually it's a silver dot
all right so they're introducing who
gods right now 27 and 4 12 knockouts see
that's the problem
do you have the power to put earl
in his place do you have the power to
keep earl at bay
you know of course you're gonna you know
try to pick earl off
uh from coming in
manny pacquiao i was always the little
guy going up to 147 is not many
pacquiao's weight class you know let's
be real
so
manny pacquiao also was knocked out
smooth colt
before
short distance
uh
replacement short time replacement cool
guys
you know he's supposed to fight spins he
thought he's gonna fight spence he
probably was up for spencing you know
felt the letdown
and spence feels like
oh gosh it's getting the recognition
that yeah
smith's over here with the laughing at
the deuce
27-0 with 21 knockouts
boy that means only six dudes made it
and survive you talk about mikey garcia
you talking about uh danny
um
you you talking about porter
uh those are the few notables that made
it to uh to the bell
so you're talking about champions but
then they write they know how to survive
[Music]
yo first of all we ain't gonna go on an
uber
who got no eyebrows man he has alopecia
that's real alopecia
keep my boxing name out your mouth
[Laughter]
you know the last time a dude made a
joke about somebody with alopecia you
know what happened to her right
when you sit and act like you're gonna
be making jokes about alopecia people
will smith might pop out the closet but
pow
[Laughter]
here we go
here we go all right so round one is
starting up
earl spencer's coming out that corner
he looks he he doesn't look dry oh guys
doesn't look dry
they both look wet paws
um and that's very important when you
when you're coming into a fight it's
very important
all right
so right off the bat
spence is uh establishing a jab olgas is
blocking
trying to go under his jab
all right so
again in the middle of the ring
spencer's jabbing
uh that's a right-handed jab because
he's a southpaw
and he's shooting the left over the top
ugas is tapping him
under his jab at his rib
so again that's a tactic
um
for southpaws
what you do is you will want to tap that
body
right under the jab
and he's continuing to do so
while spence
is jabbing keeping a high guard so
ugas
is uh
doing stuff to deter
from actually
moving forward
yeah
he's jabbing in
so
spence right now is trying to get him up
against the ropes
and
spence is trying to hit him at the waist
and come over
come under
they're both right now is a tactical
fight
in the middle of the ring uga's back
touched the ropes first so far
but he's still continuing to jab to
spence's body
um
spence
keeps his jab up and he's varying his
height and his jab you know uh he's
giving who got something to think about
with the jab
but uga's jab
is continuing
to hit directly on dispense his body all
right so spence lunged in
with um
overhand right uh left
and oogaz went straight to the body with
two digging shots
all right again
another jab
and uh spence goes straight to his body
spence is so far in control in this
round
but ugas is
doing things
to to deter spence with that jab i think
that jab
is very telling from oogaz
but again spence
is uh basically in control
a fight is gonna break out soon at some
point in time
it's uh nine seconds left in the round
and earl
is uh
pushing
while olga's finishes with a jab up top
so again we have uh
a jab fest
i think some of the most telling jabs in
that round was the
under the rib cage
of spins from oogaz
no dispenses
jabbing
all right so what what i noticed so far
in the first round
oh gosh
jab under the rib
it's pretty good but
um spence is already you know targeting
uga's face he has a little bit of
swelling
on his eye because of
he probably landed all his jabs
[Music]
so again round two is starting right now
round one i give dispense
because of the activity
and the ring general ship
okay so that
the they were a little tussle in the
middle of the ring
and you got uh
oh guys trying to go to the body of
spence and spence trying to go to the
body of ugas
now what i've noticed is oogaz stopped
with the body jab
and i think i thought that was his best
punch
i guess his corner told him they wanted
him to keep his jab up because he kept
getting hit with right hand i mean
the jab to the face okay now he's going
back to the jab to the body
all right so here we go
oh guys long reach
is um
giving earl a little bit of trouble
and
right now
the timing
is uh
turning into ugas favor
because ugaz is actually able to see a
little bit more of the shots
from spence but spence is still
controlling the pace
and dictating the fight
he's uh jabbing shooting the right hand
while keeping the high guard
he lunges too far from the outside is
spent
all right so he doubled up on a hook on
ugass's body
ugasses keeps trying to to to ring his
right hand around spencer's guard
but spencer went straight to the body
and he continued to work the body with
the jab now ej is picking up the level
of activity
because he's noticed that every time
he hits
ooh guys oh guys turtles up
oh smooth right hand
that he just i mean left handed he just
hit uga's over the top with
and that's in the middle of the ring
again
very good stuff here very high caliber
boxing
uh from both combatants um ugas
seems to be getting a little bit more
comfortable he's not throwing much but
when he does throw he does throw to land
right so
perfect
ej
landed four shots um got in got out oh
guys
tried to retaliate spence wasn't there
you have to ask yourself this question
can oh guys continue to take shots for
the rest of the night
without landing
round two is up
and that's two rounds to one i give
spence
to be honest with you
michael irvin there
the basketball player stefan jackson
von miller
you you have a ton of people there a ton
of sports guys there
sean pardon the jobber
yeah i think he job this last fight be
honest with you and keep it above
all right louis ortiz that's my dude
king kong
all right david benavidez is there in
the crowd
that's one of my guys that i got
jamel's charlo and jamal charlo
jamal good luck in your next fight we
definitely gonna be here getting it in
and we have marco parsons
all right so again we back at it round
three has just definitely started this
fight moving at a fast pace
to be honest with you spence is uh
landing shots
he's uh boogaz has clinched
spence oh spence keeps throwing that
overhand uh left
and catching oogaz
and ugas missed he he went with the
uppercut he tried to take a risk and it
didn't pay
off oh good right hand over the top from
all guys
oh spins caught him again
now the fight is heating up we're in the
third round and it's getting in they're
mixing it up and spencer's hitting him
with repeated shots
and he's under and over he's under and
over
hitting him to the body
with the left hand
to the body oh
oh gosh is going to the body too oh guys
is blocking a lot of these shots
but spence is definitely putting in that
work
oogaz
has given the illusion like everything
is okay
but spence keeps hitting him repeatedly
with the right hand
and the left hook
left under the body
left under the body left over the top
spence is leaning in
he's looking like mike mccollum right
now remember when the body snatcher used
to definitely do all that body snatching
work that's what spence is looking like
right now
so spencer's jabbing
keeping his head busy pause
right hand oh
coco
he brought it over the top
oh to the body bro to the body spence is
out of control to the body um
remember we talked about it earlier in
in
in in combat talk
uh who is the most prolific uh dude
going right now i think spence right now
and and canelo is definitely some of the
best body shots
that's out here
oh man
spence is going to the body a lot here
a lot
but ugass is fighting back now
oh shoot shoot the right
oh guys is going back
oh he hit ej with something
oh he hit ej again
he's there
he's going for it
he's going for it
is he asking for it and he's asking the
right dude to give him that answer they
about they out here mixing it up i knew
a fight was gonna break out oh
i knew a fight was gonna break out and
right now the fight has broke out
um so round four the fight is definitely
gonna start the fight is gonna hit uh
hit up yeah mike mccollum was the best
yeah he is definitely the best when he
came to the body snatcher he definitely
was the best him iran barclay
um
you gotta say james tony james tony was
able to
stay in the pocket and slit and move and
use his shoulders
perfect
excuse me philly crab style
very very good fight so far to be honest
with you very good fight so far
i i can't lie 100
this is exactly what i expected what i
was looking for what i wanted to get
from this fight and i see it i see it in
all its glory all right all right so
spencer's looking over at him like okay
so we're here now
fourth round so
spence spence had a look in his face
all right so i don't know but it's is is
the the is the hunter looking at the
prey or is is it like okay are you real
are we here all right
spence throws this um
this left hand it's a long left hand
that he throws and i i hate when he
throws that left hand
all right so here we go again he keeps
doing it but he's going to catch him oh
yeah yo uh guys has definitely got some
skills in here man well guys are
slipping some shots and and trying to
retaliate but spence is keeping him busy
i think that the overall
the ability of spence to be busy and
uga's inability to be busy is actually
dictating this fight because if ugas was
uh like on his toes type of fighter then
he would give spencer a little bit of a
headache but right now ulgas is a flat
footed uh fighter who's catching and
pitching catching his pitching is when
you know you feel the hit on the gloves
you catch and you pitch straight off the
um off the cuff so he keeps throwing his
sweeping right hand
and in the court spins a couple of times
he just threw it again ooh guys did and
but spence hits him with four or five
different shots
and this has been the whole story of the
fight so far
so
oh good low shot ooh good right hand
from oh guys
all right so right now uh spence
is uh taking a step back and olga's is
taking a step forward
but spence is continuing the the
pressure
all right the level of pressure that
spence is putting on ugas is absolutely
uh ridiculous but they're still in the
center of the ring guys so
high level boxing
uh spence is going to the body he's
moving it left to right he just got one
to pick his
body shots up because he did kind of
straight kind of low
um
but that's that's a tactic in boxing you
hit the thighs of your competitor to
slow him down uh
and you know to bring his hands down
lower so
and but it's not like oogaz is moving
around anyway so but bugas is moving
he's doing slight stepping and sliding
inside the pocket by staying present
though all right good uppercut he uh
tito shout out to my cousin tito
trinidad uh tito told uh oogaz to throw
uppercuts that's how he would beat
spence
um
yeah
i think my cousin would have a problem
with him be honest with you
yeah
how is tito my cousin
um
family name is figueroa my grandmother
name uh got arrested dead
uh her maiden name is figueroa
she comes from the same
uh province
uh in puerto rico
all right
fourth round is over again i give that
dispense
uh ugas needs to get the timing down and
he needs to start working his his jab
his right hand
um
you see nice low punch but then he's
going to throw a overhand
so yeah you know that they're both out
here actually fighting but i think
spence is putting in too much work to be
honest with you
that's right bariqua's in the house
almost outstanding
let's go let's go
all right so
normally spins in the corner
doesn't look like anything is going on
right now spencer looks like he's in a
fight
night and i'm not talking about
his facial or any bruises i'm talking
about
your posture
your posture dictates how much work that
you're putting in right and and
spence is doing a lot of work is he
seeing a lot of return back from that
work it's round five guys spencer's
going to the body
again on ugas um
olga's hasn't allowed spence to get him
to the ropes anytime spence does go to
uh get him to the ropes spins uh uga
spins off
and uh changes the direction like right
now he's leaning on spencer's neck
in a clinch
um but he's not allowing spence to pin
him against the ropes where spence does
the most of his work all right so
again ooh guys uh slipped the shot came
underneath
and while spence goes over the top and
underneath all right so
you say who got to land two shots and
spins a land five
all right but also ugas is very
cognizant of not allowing spence to get
him to the ropes and i think that is to
his detriment because he's too focused
on that and ej is doing a crap ton of
work in the middle of the ring you know
he's uh
unless you know your plan is to let this
dude land every shot and then i'll get
him later when he's tired
i have no idea
but um
okay so right now ugas is finally
starting to land the jab this is not the
same who guys that fought uh older
pacquiao
this spence right here is a absolute
monster he is landing body shots okay
here we go
ugas came up and started landing some
shots and he's landing some body shots
uh-huh
but uh spence again goes right back to
the body he's trying to dog ugas out now
he's going for a knockout
um and he's putting in the work to get a
knockout but again here comes ooh guys
who guys is fighting back now
all this is in the center of the ring
guys this is an absolute
incredible fight with nobody really
clinching um it's minor clinching going
on
but you know nothing nothing too much
nothing that that makes you you know
turn away from the fight okay so now
ugas is uh size wise is pushing earl
back and he hit earl with a 1-2 right
now
and uh went back to the pocket he hit
him with a three
over the top with that uh sweeping right
hand
earl saw it
and but actually got hit with it
earl stopped uh momentarily
with his output and earl was going right
back to the body again but ugas comes up
with shots
so again spence goes right back to the
body
with the right hook
oh gosh is in there now this is uga's
best round
this is uga's best round still ej
won the early half of the fight uga
started coming along late in the fight
you know
these shots were
actually ridiculous
you know
that was a crazy sequence of uh shots
from ej
yeah i watch ufc i watch ufc a lot
um
okay yeah he's leaning on my purpose
because that makes you tired you know
anytime somebody leans on you and put
their weight on you that's that's gonna
uh
make them a little bit weaker man if i
lean on you i put my 280 on your back my
six full 280 on your back pulse
i lean on you're gonna get tired quick
too
you guys look fresh spence looks fresh
but um be honest with you
who guys looks the the fresher of the
two
and that's just me being honest with you
maybe it's uh spencer's demeanor
you know um
again there we go spence goes right back
to the same thing that he does
i think oogaz has the sharper body
punches while spences
has the the more volume the more
thudding shots
to be honest with you
and he's he's he's he's
spencer's looking a little sloppy he's
he's looking a little sloppy
i've seen him he's falling in on shots
oogaz is is taking a lot of a lot of
hits right now they're in the middle of
the ring
and uh spence keeps uh
hitting them oh
oh olga's hit spence with a shot
and spence didn't look right
he's gonna drop the smiths spence is
weak spence is out
spencer's out on his feet
is out on his feet
spence is out on his feet
right now
spence is out on his feet right now
i told you
the mouthpiece came out
and oh guys hit him
when the mouthpiece was out
and
i don't know what the hell just happened
i got to see the replay on that because
it was kind of crazy
oh guys hit him with a shot
it was the uppercut
yeah ooh guys definitely
caught them remember i told you ulgas
was hitting him with the sharper shots
and
spence was hitting with the thunder
shots the thudding shots
and it seems like
oh guys
had him out on his feet just then
that round is definitely this round is
definitely uga's best round and the
whole fight spins doesn't look right at
all his footwork looks off
his movements look uh
sloppy i told you
he was catching shots he didn't look
right
all right well spencer's going adam
spence is going adam
but i still say you guys had him out on
his feet
because something something didn't land
right and and he's leaning on spencer's
neck
yeah
he's fighting a bigger strong guy
and i'm gonna tell you right now
this this fight right here definitely
took a turn in round six
round six if there's a round that the
fight took a turn and it took a turn in
that round right there
let me see
you said crawford would destroy spence
okay
[Music]
okay
man i don't think boxing ever lost his
shine oh yeah the mouthpiece came out
and spence was concerned with the
mouthpiece i thought he was concerned
with something else it broke his
concentration and he got caught with a
clean open shot
that stumbled him back
okay
that's kind of crazy if you get caught
with a clean shot like that that you
should have dropped the dude
remember when floyd caught uh um ortiz
with a clean open shot he dropped him
knocked him out
all right so we on round seven
spence doesn't look like he has any snap
in his shot
i think he definitely
should have um
uh what i forgot the name of his old uh
fitness trainer um
somebody hit me up and and let me know
but i definitely give that round of uh
guys that yeah that's
it's around every round spins one up
until round six i give that to you guys
to be honest with you
but spencer's falling in with his shots
oh he caught he caught him he caught him
he caught ooh guys for the uppercut and
he's going for the knockout he's going
for the knockout he caught oh god oh
gosh is holding on spencer's getting
them off him spence is chasing him
spencer's hitting him spencer's trying
to kill him out trying to knock him out
kill the beast while he's wounded finish
him off this is how you finish him off
he caught him with a punch uh he wasn't
looking in that last fight well i mean
the last round and spins definitely
closing ooga's eye he's stepping on his
feet right now uh bringing him into the
shot uh spence definitely got pissed off
uh from the last round but again i told
you he was looking sluggish
oh gosh is fighting back
all right okay let's go let's go let's
go this is what i want i don't want you
to go to sleep i want you to stay here
for the whole night
come on let's go there we go
ej looking good now looking clean
moving i don't know what he was doing i
don't know if he got lackadaisical in
there i don't know his his brain was
someplace else but uh ugass is in this
fight the wind pushed them off uh
survived that minor fury uh right there
uh-huh
here we go
jab in right hand
here we go here we go there we go i mean
driving left hook oh guys keeps trying
to come up the middle
keeps trying to come up the middle ej
keeps falling in with his shots looking
for the uppercut body shots he keeps
going to the body he keeps investing in
the body he has to watch out for ugas
uppercut uh-huh there we go
oh and ugass is fighting back right now
all right oh
uh spence with a straight uh straight
left straight down the pipe caught
olga's and he keeps coming over the top
with some punches uh-huh
there we go and
oh that would have been a ko shot from
ugas because spence keeps falling in
with his shots to be honest with you
all right spencer's going to the body
bringing up the uppercut oh man he gave
us everything that he can handle in this
round to be honest with you he keeps
missing this sweeping uh punch that he
keeps throwing
but he keeps going for uga's body oh
guys is still standing in the pockets
too you guys are still focused who got
makes it out of that round that's a damn
good round
oh my god that was a damn good round
just like round six was a good round
round seven was a great round was even
better round be honest with you um
because the mouthpiece came out and then
he caught spins for the shot but spence
caught him with an uppercut
and here comes the uppercut that he
caught him with boom right between the
guard olga's had his guard tight
suspense came up through the guard and
spence is throwing from the hip
from the hip
all right so and you know ugass is
trying to catch spence when spence
uh throws a shot um let me tell you
something
for anybody that feels that bud would
have destroyed uh spence
um
in my opinion he was down in that fight
uh
with uh crawford i mean with um porter
um
styles make fights we gotta see if if
bud could take a big strong guy uh with
the work rate of earl
you know um but the fight ain't over
you know blood could be fighting oh guys
because ugas definitely has some stuff
in his tank you know so
let's see exactly what happens
um
okay oh the dude like i told y'all
before i i think um earl has a uh injury
with his leg because when ugass pushes
him back i don't like how earl
uh rocks back and forth with his leg
anyway the the guy was blu-ray blu-ray
was his uh earl's old um
uh strength and conditioning trainer and
i think he needs to go back to blu-ray
to be honest with you i think blu-ray is
who he needs to work with um because
i've never seen him get pushed back
uh with the two hands as much as he's
doing right now because cool guys is
pushing him back with the two hands but
olga's is taking a a ton of shots uga's
eye is completely closed
all right um on his uh what is that is
his right side his right side eye is
completely closed
um and i think earl had something to
prove
with that because they told earl that
his eye won't hold up and right now
uga's eye is closed all right and earl
has something to prove earl wants to
knock this man out cold i think that has
dictated um some of the sloppiness that
i've seen from earl
in this fight uh i think earl
uh respects olga's but the stuff that
they were saying
and his trainer leading up to the fight
uh brought out a different beast earl is
landing shots and i think you need to
see the copy box after this that's
ridiculous earl is going to the body to
the head the whole round right now is
all earl earl is throwing
body shots that is disgusting
all right so he spit out the mouthpiece
oh no no no he didn't they um they
telling him to go to the corner to check
his eye all right ooga's eye
all right um
oga's eye is still slightly open he can
still see
um but remember he doesn't have any hair
there so it looks a lot worse than it
actually is to be honest with you um
they're doing something excessive this
is excessive right now
uh the guy is still fighting he told you
i can see he said everything is fine but
they have this corner guy over here they
give an earl too much time to rest
they're giving uh ooh guys too much time
to rest
um
but yeah
you guys can can completely go on i
don't know why the referee did that i
can't stand this guy jack whatever the
hell his name is jack reese or whatever
his name is um
earl's right back to business he's going
right back at uh olga's he's landing
shots from the bottom to the top uga's
just threw a shot right back trying to
get earl off for him um
earl is going for the ko
he said he was going to go for the ko um
olgas is fighting back right
now uh i think that break gave ugas some
uh a second win orgasm is coming up
through the middle earl is uh standing
close to him shoulder to shoulder uh
throwing shots up the middle over the
top and over the sides all right there's
10 seconds left in the eighth round oh
guys throws a sweeping right hand
catches earl on the side of the air earl
goes right back up the middle and right
back to the sides the round is at the
end
i'ma tell you right now
up until that last round i thought
earl's looking a little sloppy
um when the mouthpiece came out i don't
know why the mouthpiece came out but he
was distracted who guys hit him with a
shot and had him on queer street to be
honest with you was it legal clean shot
but he had him on question to be honest
with you earl came out this round and it
was like he was trying to prove a point
i think earl's been trying to prove a
point uh since this fight started he's
been
very sloppy uh to be honest with you
very sloppy but
ugas is in a fight he's not out of the
fight but his eye is bad
all right his eye is bad his eye is
closed okay um
and earl just doesn't care he keeps
targeting it
and he keeps hammering that eye
that's the second time this is the
second time i've seen him
uh exhibit a level of viciousness um
that is very really exhibited in boxing
um the last time he told him mikey was
going to uh outbox him
spence carried him for the whole fight
just beating him from pillar to post
this fight right now he's determined
to take this guy's eye out his head be
honest with you
um because the body shots he's okay so
the round just started he's going right
back to the body he has oogas against
the ropes right and he's hitting him
with body shots that is absolutely
disgusting folks um but ugas every so
often does okay right hand boom to the
body earl is undetermined uh undeterrent
um
right now earl is putting
his body shot this is disgusting all
right here's jack reese again
telling earl to lift his shots up
because earl is going nothing but to the
body and to the head man now he's
forcing early goes straight up to
uppercuts and right hands earl is
pushing them to the ropes so the left
hook to the side of the air alright so
now
earl is going straight to the head he's
head hunting and he's bringing
everything up the middle
um
and he's uh pushing ugas back
uh uga still hasn't been up against the
ropes
and i think
ugas has uh
learned
not to get close to the ropes with earl
because earl does his best work
against the ropes earl back is against
the ropes right now but he just knocked
ooga's back off of him and he just
pushed
earl back i'm telling you right now i
honestly believe earl has a problem with
his foot
um and he gets pushed back very easy
spence oh oh god straight to the body
hit spins
beautiful all right so there was a break
in the shot um
he's hitting oogaz is protecting his eye
and he's going to spence's body but i
think he heard spins to the body a
couple of times just then
and
he he dug it under
when uh spence wasn't looking ugas is
trying to protect the eye
um because listen the eye is really bad
i i think honestly
yeah see yeah
he hurt earl to the body
he care he hurt earl to the body i don't
care what nobody said
he hurt earl to the body
listen when you're in a fight
you're going to you're going to catch
shots you're going to get hit
all right this this referee
is probably the worst referee going
because he keeps breaking up the action
when there's no need okay so we got nine
seconds left in the round of ten
earl
does he have a cut over his eye
um
not that i know of
all right
good right hand
end of the round
oh oh my god
oh god's nose is swollen
his eye is closed
there could be a stoppage but there is
no stoppage
there could be a stoppage but there is
no stoppage um
ugas has never put his back up against
the ropes if ugaz was against the ropes
taking those shots that he's taken in
the middle of the ring they would stop
the fight but the fact that he's in the
middle of the ring taking those shots
and he's turning every time earl gets
ahead of steam and then he moves off
every time earl gets ahead of steam
um it's definitely something completely
totally different so no
i honestly
think that um
if he had his back up against the ropes
it would be over
but it's not and and they're they're
fighting here we go all right so we have
round ten
oogaz has a hell of a push-off game
all right so that that push-off um he
should incorporate that into a punch
push off then
rush up to you like a bull rug and and
all right hand
because his push-off game is crazy
spence is right back at trying to knock
him out and he's keeps going for the
shot so all right so the fact that ugas
is not letting his right hand goal and
he's keeping it close to cover of his
eye he just let his right hand go there
spins blocked it twice and he keeps
shooting the right okay so spence is oh
oh my god all guys went back he took a
shot okay
oh guys with it a little bit but he's
still there
spence is uh throwing shots from many
angles many different angles the double
oh the eye the eye his eye is not making
it
every time spence hits them in the eye
uh who guys uh
uh curls back in um pain
um
i'ma tell you man i want to hear what
spence has to say after this
um
oh man
these shots is debilitating oogaz is
running back it's not much that he can
do
uh spence keeps landing these shots
um 10th round
uh
might be over there's a minute 24 to go
uh spence is tracking him
here comes the stupid referee again
and bringing him to the corner again let
the man finish on his feet
if his corner doesn't throw in a towel
mind your business
oh man it's lit oh
snap his lip just exploded something
crazy oh referee stop the fight
referee stop the fight
referee stop the fight i mean
errol yo i'm gonna tell you right now
arrows earl earl
earl's going to talk a hell of a lot of
mess after this fight and and and
rightfully so
danis uh
came to fight he put up a good fight
he caught earl with a with a very good
shot in my opinion
excuse me
but they told earl
that his eye would not hold up in his
fight
and isn't it ironic that your eyes
didn't hold up in his fight
oh man
it's not cuban pride this fight is pride
man every every fighter that walks in
that ring should have that level of he
said he looked like cyclops she's stupid
um
every every every fighter that goes into
that ring has a level of pride so let's
let's keep it a buck you know uga's went
in there with the pride of a fighter
um
and and and yo
your boy
got that work put it
but uh
listen guys this has been fantastic
uh the fight is over so it ain't no
decision for us to go to look for any
decision
uh we had a little rough start have a
busted phone
next time we're gonna have some stuff a
little bit different a little bit better
drinks up
catch out tomorrow on iop
thank y'all for rocking with the king
it's been a fantastic evening i
appreciate each and every last one of
you y'all was here 100 percent
earl spence in this victory do we get
crawford is crawford next
shout out to y'all catch out tomorrow
yo hit that like at the bottom share
that out it's definitely dope
you guys did it up
i love each and every last one of you
thank you for rocking out with me man
i'm rocking with you all day long man
facts shout out to uh
1090 jake that's my dude love all your
stuff i'm gonna end the stream peace out
my